okay well hello everybody my name is
bruce korf i'm a medical geneticist
serve as the chair of the department of
genetics at university of alabama at
birmingham
pleasure to have an opportunity to speak
with you today and i was asked to talk
about the educational challenges brought
about by the opportunity to integrate
genetics and genomics into medical
practice i know that you have the
opportunity to
ask questions and
my plan is to
you can ask questions at any time but
we'll take all of the questions after
i've had a chance to complete the
presentation also should note that i do
not have any conflicts to disclose
relevant to this talk
by way of background i think it's well
understood that there is a huge
opportunity before us in terms of using
the power of genetics and genomics
to inform health care but at the same
time there has been a lot of concern
about the degree to which the healthcare
community is prepared to embrace
genetics and genomics i quote here from
a report from
the secretary's advisory committee on
genetics health and society
and i
won't read the um quote to you
but it's an example of the kind of
concern
that has been very widespread most
physicians in practice and i think this
would apply to other health care
professionals as well
did not train in the genomics era so
even if they were exposed to concepts of
genetics during their training
the world has changed almost
180 degrees since the time that they did
train so very very few
non-genetics professionals currently in
practice
trained
for the current environment never mind
the environment yet to come
so there is a challenge in terms of the
pipeline of professionals
but then especially a challenge in terms
of the current practitioners
for them to get up to speed on what is
in many respects a kind of sea change in
the way medicine is going to be
practiced
a lot of my comments then will follow
from this challenge where are we
what are the kinds of things that might
be possible to do in order to bring us
to where we all i think would like to be
i'm going to tell you a short anecdote
which
maybe casts into relief some of the
challenges
that we're facing and this is a case
that was seen in our genetics clinic
and it concerns a child
who
comes from a family
with a history of multiple endocrine
neoplasia type one it's an autosomal
dominant trait and the features are
shown up in the left side of the slide
multiple endocrine tumors i won't lead
all of these to you and in fact some
non-endocrine tumors as well
he came to attention because of chronic
diarrhea and
was referred for evaluation to a
pediatric endocrinologist
because the family history raised the
question of whether the diarrhea might
have been on the basis of
having inherited the gene for this
disorder
so the endocrinologist went ahead and
did a genetic test on the child
and
the test was sent to a commercial
laboratory now i'm not showing you the
actual result as it came back from the
lab um but this is a reproduction that's
pretty much the same as what the report
said which is that they found a mutation
in the relevant gene
or variant
and somehow not exactly sure how
they positioned it about midway between
the possibility that it was a pathogenic
variant and a benign variant as i'm sure
you're aware
genetic variants by themselves
sometimes can have significant
phenotypic effects other times they have
no phenotypic effects and this one
somehow was placed right smack in the
middle
well the endocrinologist actually
interpreted this as
being indicative of the child in fact
being affected
and
the medical record was
then indicated that this child had
inherited a multiple endocrine neoplasia
gene and
the care was adjusted accordingly we'll
say in a minute
what that means
well some time passed and the mother
then was seen
in a adult endocrinology clinic because
of
various medical concerns
and the endocrinologist was
not entirely convinced of the diagnosis
in the family and as a result
sent
testing on her but the way it was
arranged in this case was that she was
referred to the genetics clinic and
his expectation was that the genetics
clinic would order the testing and it
was done
was sent to an academic lab who
identified a known pathogenic mutation
that is to say a mutation that had been
previously
documented in other families and other
individuals
as being responsible for multiple
endocrine neoplasia it was different
than the mutation that the child had
been found to have and in fact the
mother was not found to carry that
variant of unknown significance so
presumably it came from the father and
is not a pathogenic mutation
and the child
as best we know did not have the
mother's pathogenic mutation i put it
that way because the commercial lab
assured the counselor that they would
have seen this pathogenic mutation if it
were there
so
at this point it was clear that the
child had in fact not
inherited the pathogenic mutation in the
family
by the way did verify the mother's
diagnosis
and
to tell you that it's been difficult and
probably to this day
depending on where you look in the
medical record you might get the
impression
that the child indeed is affected since
it tends to be very difficult to undo
an erroneous diagnosis in the medical
record
so if you
conceptualize the
kind of case in terms of
competencies that you would hope
that a clinician would have and i'm
thinking of the child's position
you would say well the first thing you'd
want to know is that they paid attention
to family history
and determined that the child actually
could be at risk based on the pattern of
inheritance of this disorder and that
competency was demonstrated
you can say that the child would benefit
from having a diagnosis that's actually
questionable at 18 months the
recommendations for follow-up do begin
in children but maybe not quite that
young on the other hand the child
did have a potential symptom and so you
could argue that that competency was
achieved incidentally
failed to mention that when all was said
and done the
diarrheal is due to gastroenteritis
the third is to
know how to order mem1 genetic testing
and clearly that competency was achieved
and then to appreciate the variant of
the significance of the variant of
unknown significance in particular to
realize that unknown significance
well means unknown significance and not
establishes a diagnosis and here i think
you can say that competency was not
achieved
in fact you would really prefer to test
an affected known affected relative that
would have been the mother most probably
in this case first
because the significance of a mutation
test
is much greater when you know the family
mutation and then a negative test means
that the child didn't inherit it as
opposed to that maybe the diagnosis was
incorrect or mutation couldn't be
identified with current technology and
that clearly was also not
exercised here
formulated a appropriate care plan i
guess it's kind of an ambiguous point
because you would have had to have a
correct diagnosis to do that
so really my point here is that there
are many competencies that you would
expect of a in this case specialist some
of which were evidenced and some of
which ultimately were not
so you could ask the question
what are the necessary
knowledge and skill sets that are
required for analyzing
interpreting and utilizing genomic
information
and
one of the major themes that i would
like to set forth is that we need to be
focusing on
competencies not knowledge in this case
the competency is the broad competency
of utilizing genomic information in the
context of a clinical question and that
can be in turn broken down into many
specific competencies such as i did on
the previous slide
i would argue as we go forward i will
that point of care decision support
tools may guide clinical use at least in
some circumstances
but also
that doesn't get the health provider off
the hook for at least having some idea
of what they're doing and
the stern visage of abraham flexner who
wrote a report about 100 years ago that
moved the u.s medical education system
from the kind of trade school
approach that had been prevalent at the
time
to the scientific basis for medical
practice that all of us know today
will remind you of the importance that
we don't expect health providers only to
just know which buttons to press to have
at least some idea of what's going on
behind the scenes not necessarily an
intimate idea
of all the nuts and bolts but at least
not
to believe that the results come about
due to magic in some way shape or form
so i'd like to do briefly is to consider
very broadly three
kinds of scenarios that is prevention of
disease
diagnosis and treatment
and provides some
suggestions of how and where genetics
and genomics are likely to be used and
what we would expect of various of the
health providers in the context of
providing this care
the first example
with regard to prevention is
actually a
well-known one one with which many
physicians are quite familiar
this being newborn screening we have
practiced newborn screening or inborn
errors of metabolism in this country and
throughout the developed world
um for about 50 years now the paradigm
began
with the idea illustrated at the upper
left in phenylketonuria that if you made
a diagnosis at
birth before toxic
accumulation of phenylalanine took place
that you could avoid the kind of dire
outcome shown at the lower left
by
avoiding dietary intake of phenylalanine
and achieve the much more
satisfactory outcome shown at the right
and over the years
in various states in the u.s and around
the world
the
paradigm has expanded to multiple inborn
errors of metabolism
and this got a big boost in the 90s and
to the present day with the advent of
tandem mass spectrometry you don't need
to know
that much about it
from our perspective to realize that
it has the ability to detect abnormal
metabolites
of very large
variety of types as opposed to the old
guthrie plate which is what the woman in
the
in the center of the upper left panel is
looking at where you had to custom
design a specific panel for each
particular disorder that you were trying
to diagnose
well in fact one of the challenges that
you encounter when you expand the
newborn screening panel as has been done
and now there's a standard panel that
the american college of medical genetics
and genomics has put together
that is used in most if not all states
in the
u.s improving a situation by the way
that used to be the case which was
depending on where you were born
determined what you were screened for
but the challenge now becomes if you're
the physician presumably usually a
pediatrician who receives a call from
the state lab friday at 4 30 in the
afternoon
that your
patient has just been
found to be screened positive for a
condition that very probably you have
never heard of and if you ever did hear
of it you
probably haven't seen another patient
with it are not likely to be intimately
familiar with the way management is done
and although you are almost certainly
going to seek support from a metabolic
disease expert you do need to be the
first responder for the family to deal
with things in the immediate few hours
at least or days before you can engage a
specialist consultant
and tied them over the kind of immediate
needs
i'm showing you on this screen
a set of shots of so-called act sheets
that are put out by the american college
of medical genetics and genomics this
particular one
involves
a very long chain basal coa
dehydrogenase deficiency a rare disorder
to be sure one likely not on the kind of
tip of the tongue of most pediatricians
and basically what it's intended to do
is to tell you the immediate things that
you need to pay attention to and
what are the things you would do for the
hours or days before you get a
specialist involved and it provides
simple algorithms
and i make the point really it's
obviously not really genomics but it is
a kind of paradigm of providing
point of care
decision support systems
that actually are intended to be
embedded in electronic health records so
at this point they're more likely to be
available on online
as
web-based
assistance
but the concept here is that it helps
the physician get through the day would
be unrealistic to teach all
pediatricians how to take care of all
the inborn errors
but this
is a way of kind of holding their hands
uh through the immediate things that
they need to pay attention to and i
think the paradigm potentially is a
powerful one
what about in the area of
risk assessment and i show a screenshot
of
three companies that either have been or
are
in the business of offering direct
direct-to-consumer
testing of
usually a million or so single
nucleotide polymorphisms these can be
accessed over the internet with the
paradigm being that you send a saliva
sample
to the company that they test for these
polymorphisms and then give you access
to usually web-based information
that walks you through
various disease risks that might be
identified
on the basis of this analysis
not all of the companies that started in
this
domain are still in business doing this
so perhaps the marketplace has spoken to
a degree it's created a lot of um angst
in terms of consumers accessing this
information without the intervention of
a physician but there are many that
would take the point of view that it's
the individual who owns their own genome
more or less and therefore
should have the right to information
without a medical system telling them
that they can't see it
i think that whatever you believe about
that
concept that we could conceptualize this
direct-to-consumer model
as an example of the so-called
disruptive technology it's a term
perhaps some of you are familiar with
that has been coined in the business
community this is a chart modified from
a kind of
canonical chart that clay christensen
who's popularized this concept
is put together the idea is that we are
currently functioning in a kind of
traditional mode shown on the red line
of
a physician and or counselor
meeting in a room with a patient one
gene at a time
one patient at a time and as time passes
as we get more information about the
genome the quality of those visits
should improve you sort of march up this
curve
but not that steeply because it's a
pretty mature paradigm one that people
have a lot of experience with
in contrast the consumer driven testing
at this point in time is the green line
and that we're at the bottom left corner
where the performance is really not very
impressive and i mean by that that the
quality of the risk data is questionable
it's based on mostly
genome-wide association studies
the odds ratio of
having disease given the presence of a
particular marker is usually very
modestly changed from the population
risk there could be questions about what
population was actually tested and
whether it applies to the particular
population of a given consumer
so some people have called this kind of
recreational genomics um and it's
interesting and maybe fun but debatable
about how much it informs your health
care and i
you can take different points of view on
that but whatever you believe i guess i
would at least suggest the possibility
that as the quality of the data sets get
better and better we may sort of march
up this green curve
to the point where it actually crosses
the red line and becomes the sort of
sustaining technology
an example of a disruptive technology is
the personal computer which in the 1970s
was really nowhere near capable of doing
what a mainframe computer could do say
to run a business and as you know now
the personal computer has
really dominated the computer industry
so
perhaps the same thing will happen
perhaps not it's always hard to predict
disruption before it's occurred but at
least i posit this for your
consideration
what about diagnostic testing and how
has genomics
changed all of that the paradigm we're
most familiar with is like sickle cell
or cystic fibrosis illustrated here
where we're focusing on single gene
disorders where
a particular genetic test targets a very
specific mutation
it's not always so easy the lower right
shows a diagram of the neurofibromatosis
type 1 gene which happens to be my area
of special interest and
the lab here at uab offers testing and
each dot below the gene represents a
different mutation in a different person
you know the opposite is
in sickle cell where everybody has the
same mutation um cf is a kind of middle
ground where a few mutations comprise
the majority but after that there could
be potentially thousands and then nf no
one mutation is more than a few percent
so it ranges in complexity from fairly
straightforward to extremely challenging
now
we are in the era of genomic testing for
clinical purposes
the example shown here in the upper
right is a cytogenomic microarray you
can probably barely see it but it would
be capable of detecting at the very
bottom an exceedingly small in this case
deletion
well below the limits of light
microscopic resolution and yet which can
explain for example an autism spectrum
disorder with a much higher diagnostic
pickup rate
than
classic cytogenetics for example
and most recently the concept of doing
exome or even genome sequencing
has
been introduced as a clinical test
with the goal being to avoid the
so-called diagnostic odyssey where
patients are seen clinical problem is
subjected to differential diagnosis you
make your best guesses which test to do
it's interpreted if it's the wrong test
you don't get an answer and you just
keep going in circles here sometimes for
years costing a very large amount of
money and often not casting light on
what the ultimate diagnosis is
in recent years the possibility of doing
genomic testing with an eye towards
identifying specific pathogenic
mutations
increasingly is being used and is being
covered by insurance
we do have to realize that diagnostic
testing based on
this approach
will often pick up things that
there may not be
the original target i'll say more about
incidental findings in a few minutes
this is a screenshot from a paper
published a few years ago
and basically shows that just the
frequency of carrier status for
recessive disorders
virtually everybody is a carrier for
something
so if you set the bar at that level
they're all going to turn out to have
things that may or may not be relevant
to our health and they may not be
relevant
to the question being asked so it's a
complex area and they also found many
examples of
what were thought to be literature
annotated disease mutations that in fact
were not correctly annotated so one has
to take some of the genomic data
with a bit of a grain of salt or better
stated with a critical eye and a
sophisticated critical eye and and not
to take at face value um results that
may not have been completely vetted
sometimes these mutations were based on
a single case report 30 years ago
that may or may not hold up to modern
scrutiny
but we've been doing genetic testing
in
even common disorders for a while this
is an example of a family history a
proband shown at the lower right
with a sister with breast cancer and a
family history on her father's side of
multiple people with breast or ovarian
or prostate cancer was concerned that
she might be a brca carrier we organized
to test her sister who had breast cancer
her sister was test positive for brca1
mutation
that permitted us to test our patient
and when she was found to be negative
that has a very substantial power for
her because we know that the family
history was accounted for by a brca
mutation and we know we could detect it
and didn't and that means her risk
reverts essentially to the population
risk
not
informed anymore by her family history
so diagnostic testing for
risk of at least the mendelian versions
of common diseases
i think at this point become mainstream
so what competencies do you expect of a
physician on some of these i've already
talked about with the multiple endocrine
neoplasia family to recognize the
indications for testing know the right
member of the family to test first not
always so straightforward and also could
be challenging in terms of who's going
to pay for the testing
you need to be able to discuss
that very point and what the risks and
benefits of testing including potential
anxiety and stigmatization
to then correctly select the lab
interpret the report
um if it's genomic sequencing you're
doing to recognize the potential for
secondary findings to make appropriate
referrals and to discuss the results
that may or may not be
the kind of definitive discussion you
may engage a genetic counselor
to help with that but you still need to
be prepared at least to support the
family
about in the therapeutic realm where
lots of things are going on there i show
here a screenshot of the um kind of
structure of the bcr able
fusion gene in chronic myelogenous
leukemia which is targeted by the drug
imatinib mesolate which represents a
very well i think
known example of tailoring a particular
drug to a particular genetic lesion
it's a paradigm that
sort of stands as the holy grail in many
ways of new therapeutic development you
probably don't need honestly to know a
lot about genetics to use it
you need to know a lot about genetics to
develop it and that's something that
continues the continuity to at least
know that genetic testing will stratify
patients with disease as to whether they
won't benefit from this in certain
circumstances
i realize you can't see this well but
this is meant to indicate
the ability to do testing
of the
egf receptor in
breast cancer
looking at
response to drugs that target that or a
particular
b raft mutation that
determines sensitivity to specific drugs
in melanoma
and now increasingly even whole genome
sequencing is being applied in cancer
therapeutics to make a precise diagnosis
and to select the most appropriate
mechanism of treatment so we have moved
towards a kind of
so-called precision medicine model at
least in some areas especially in cancer
there are also pharmacogenetic
polymorphisms that can be tested
that provide the possibility of
adjusting drug dosage according to the
metabolism of the given individual this
diagram
shows the metabolism of
warfarin very commonly used
anticoagulant
where the v core c1 target of warfarin
is subject to polymorphisms that
determine its sensitivity to warfarin
and the cyp2c9
gene is involved in metabolism of
warfarin and you can use testing of the
two of these to identify the likely
optimal dose of warfarin for a given
patient
it is pretty clearly
clinically valid it is still being
subjected to clinical trials though to
establish clinical utility and
cost-effectiveness
this is an example i think of a kind of
test that is likely to be incorporated
into electronic prescribing systems
whether physicians will ever need to
know in their head how to addre adjust
drug dosage warfarin i'm not so sure but
you can easily imagine it would sit in
the background in a
electronic prescribing system and then
inform the
drug dosage that is chosen
a lot of people have um wondered about
the possibility of
genome sequencing and actually as i look
at the slide i can see some
errors in terms of the translation from
the platform where they were created to
the
display platform here but i don't think
it has any major effect
the question would be should everybody
have their genome sequence and if they
did
when would you do it and where would you
keep the information
it's possible to actually do a prenatal
genome sequence even on the
very small amount of fetal dna that
is released usually from the placenta
into the maternal circulation and is now
already being used for non-invasive
prenatal screening could be used for
even prenatal
genome sequencing
you can imagine doing it instead of the
newborn screen metabolic test that's
currently done
that i've already talked about
either of these raises a lot of
questions about do you want to know
about adult onset disorders prenatally
or in the newborn period
you could do it in childhood you still
have at least the possibility of
intervening but
complexity of knowing about things that
are not immediately relevant to the
health of the child
or you can do it in adulthood when you
can certainly provide informed consent
about the procedure
but if you wait till then you have lost
the opportunity to intervene at an
earlier point
and if it were to be done you could ask
the question where would the information
live
so one possibility shown at the lower
left is in the electronic health record
which probably makes the stewards of
these records and different institutions
a bit nervous to realize the vast
storage requirements that would be
expected of them although probably
storage will become cheaper and cheaper
as time goes on making that a
possibility but another challenge faced
is that most people do not spend their
entire lifetime receiving health care
from a single
place wherever it might be academic or
otherwise people tend to move around
over time or you might be traveling when
some medical event occurs that requires
or at least would be informed by genomic
information so
not clear whether the ehr is the right
place to put this unless electronic
health records
share information
back and forth more than they currently
do
you could store the information in the
cloud wherever exactly that really is as
long as you trusted the security of the
information
maybe that would be a solution if it's
already being considered in many cases
maybe you would store it on some kind of
personal device you carry with you which
is fine as long as you don't forget it
or and this is becoming my favorite um
so far as we know the most efficient
place to store genetic information is
the cell nucleus and nobody ever forgets
to bring their cell nuclei to the doctor
and it may be that the cost of
sequencing will pump it to a point where
it's essentially almost free and it will
be cheaper to repeat the sequence as
needed than to bother storing it
anywhere
i actually just don't know which of
these various possibilities or any
combination of them is likely to take
effect and really ignoring here the vast
effort that needs to go into annotation
and the informatics although i predict
that that too will become a lot easier
as the technology improves
but argue that the paradigm that we
really need to be seeking is to
find a way to store and process
information which is as user friendly
and fun to use as itunes which is the
screenshot you're looking at and i'm
often asked when do i think physicians
will use genomic sequencing in the
course of their day-to-day treatment and
my answer is the day that somebody
creates an itunes-like interface instead
of the
in my opinion very
awkward electronic health records that
most of us are using
that were really not built for the
genomic era
unfortunately are so expensive and
complex that they evolve very very
slowly
i've alluded to the possibility of
incidental findings and i showed this
picture
as a kind of paradigm
looking at a guy that
was just hit on head by a flower pot
that fell on him uh with a passerby
trying to come to his aid and i used
that
sort of picture because
probably many of you know that in the
last year the american college of
medical genetics and genomics has
proposed that laboratories that are
doing exome or genome sequencing
query 56 genes for specific types of
mutations an example would be the
brca one and two genes
that those results be returned to the
referring position regardless of whether
the test was done for that reason
that the patients not be asked whether
they do or don't want those lab results
returned
the idea would be that the physician
understands the patient's circumstances
better than the lab does
and can contextualize the results decide
what and how to share with the patient
and provide appropriate support and
counseling in the process it's been a
controversial recommendation
the genes were chosen very carefully i'm
sure we've left some off
that could potentially find their way on
the list and the doubt that the list
will stay just as it is forever but um
the thinking was this is a bit analogous
to finding an unexpected pulmonary
nodule and a chest x-ray that's being
done to
see if somebody fractured a rib
you don't ask do i want to know about
the possibility of incidental
cancer
identification or potential cancer it's
not even then a guaranteed result that
it would be a cancer we assume that that
kind of thing is too important to ignore
and that was the same spirit in which
these recommendations were made though i
know that there's been a lot of debate
about
how this be implemented and
whether patients should be given more
opportunity to opt out of this and it's
a debate that's likely to continue
although my personal belief is that
these are conditions that
are so overwhelmingly penetrated
medically actionable they'd really be
hard to argue why
that would not report these if they knew
they were present but anyway that can be
discussed at another point
well
to kind of get to the um
sort of end point here in terms of
education
what are we faced with if you look at
the human genome um you can
conceptualize it as
this you know file of letters and many
people have
likened this to so-called book of life
or i like to think of it really as the
library of life anyway
and
you know you can
kind of remember back to your training
and say well you know what's the the
language of the genome and the answer is
three letter codons then encode
particular amino acids
so it would be possible to say well so
what's an example of a book
that uses predominantly three-letter
words
and the one that comes to mind is this
one
and it would be possible to say well
just how hard could this be if things
are as simple as that and my
feeling is that this is not a very good
metaphor for the genome that in fact the
better one if you want to use a literary
metaphor is this book which any of you
who have tried to read it will
acknowledge it's not easy going that you
could teach a
first grader to read ulysses i would
expect if what you mean by that is
pronounce the words but the complexity
the knowledge you need to have of the
illusions that are used in this book the
ability to read between the lines and to
get the kind of
back story that the author is
communicating is very very sophisticated
and frankly that is very similar to what
we're dealing with in genetics and
genomics it might look simple from a
distance and the farther you get into it
the more you realize that it has
complexities that are not that obvious
finally another literary metaphor is it
doesn't take long to pass through the
looking glass in genomics where the
rules you thought you knew when we're
taught don't apply where a gene mutation
for example that should obliterate
expression of a gene actually changes
splicing patterns not turning off the
gene entirely
or
conservative mutations or even
mutations that don't change the amino
acid alter splicing patterns
unpredictably or imprinting effects so
that this is a lot more complicated
than it sometimes seems on the surface
so
what are the training needs and i would
argue here that we need to establish
what you could think of as a vector of
competency that begins actually before
matriculation into professional
education for example in undergraduate
years
we need to then
enhance that through their medical
education and for physicians through
residency training and then lifelong
learning through continuing medical
education and maintenance of
certification in the latter may be an
area of opportunity for the already
practicing physician
we also need to do a better job
attracting students to careers in
genetics
from the perspective of both pre-medical
and medical school education
the howard hughes medical institute and
association of american medical colleges
a few years ago issued a report
shown here on scientific foundations for
future physicians but they tried to
identify the competencies in basic
science that would be important for
future physicians and one of their
recommendations was to enhance the
scientific training in the pre-medical
years so that students came to medical
school better prepared and then could
carry that forward through medical
school
this is a very high level document
meaning not a lot of fine detail about
particular curricula this is the one
competency that addresses medical
education in genetics
as the one geneticist on this committee
i guess i can take responsibility for
what was left out of here
but it really is a kind of
all-encompassing thing you might say
this is covering a tremendous amount of
territory and it is and this kind of
competency is paradigmatic of what was
done in other medical specialties too
and it leaves the details of which there
obviously are many to faculty in terms
of actually how to
instill these competencies
in the medical schools and medical
students and training
a few years ago here at uab we actually
extended this concept to not just the
undergraduates who were in pre-health
professional type
programs but also
to general undergraduates thinking you
know maybe you're not going to pursue a
career in health professions but
if you're going to be a consumer of
so-called personalized health care or
genomic medicine you need to be a more
sophisticated consumer
if you're
headed to a career in business law or
engineering there are opportunities we
broke it down into genomics
pharmacogenetics informatics and
cultural and environmental influences on
health and try to identify competencies
that
would be useful in all of these and
customized to these different
usually undergraduate or in some cases
graduate education
kind of modes
so there's a lot to be done in terms of
preparing physicians in general
for the use of genetics and genomics and
for building a professional genetics
workforce also the genetics community
has met twice about this in recent years
at the banbury conference center
near cold spring harbor
once in 2004 and then again in 2006
um the first of those meetings was
focused on how can we increase the
training pipeline into genetics and the
second into defining what the medical
geneticist actually does
since it is a relatively new specialty
that has come of age
originally in the pre-genomic era and
now in the genomic era
the american college of medical genetics
and genomics has defined competencies
for the physician medical geneticist
this particular competency focuses on
translational research and clinical
trials which have become a kind of
mainstream aspect of genetics practice
and this one on providing counseling to
individuals based on genome or exome
sequencing so there's you know a lot
going on there
acmg has also been working to try to
increase the pipeline encouraging
students to
medical students this is
to be aware of career opportunities and
to
be connected
with the genetics programs at your
institution
now for the past three years the summer
scholars program has taken medical
students
one student sometimes two
in 10 to 20 institutions around the
country that apply for a slot
and these students spend the summer with
a stipend provided to acmg foundation
to
actually work in a genetics unit
observing clinics participating in lab
activities sometimes
picking up a project it's been going
only a few years it's probably too soon
to judge how successful it will be but
the hope is that it will provide a kind
of sensitization to the opportunity that
will bring more people and we don't need
every third medical student to go into
genetics but there is the possibility of
doing a genetics residency and certainly
the opportunities to increase the
numbers are really quite significant and
important
we also i think when it comes to
educating the generalist physician or
specialist in other areas you need to
realize not everybody by any means is
going to do a genetics residency which
is a two-year residency by the way
that is recognized by the american board
of medical specialties
but not everybody is going to go that
route or should and that we need to use
every opportunity at our disposal to
educate the workforce through new
educational paradigms i shall hear
examples of the massive open online
courses
khan academy model for
delivering micro lectures on different
topics
we created an ibook here at uab to
support a course we give
on genetics and genomics and clinical
research twice a year to clinical
investigators and other novel paradigms
such as this one
can be used as well
so there'll be lots of opportunities to
try to develop
new approaches
well so what ultimately is needed and i
will identify a few things going forward
um the first is really more of a
scientific challenge but we are a long
way
from having a fully annotated genome
which means that
it's going to be a long time before you
can take genome sequence at face value
and just say well you've got this
variant and here's what it means
that is true for certain variants it is
not true for many and knowing the
difference between the two is what the
kind of professional training really
needs to accomplish
second as i've already too many times we
need point-of-care decision support
tools to be deployed to support the
clinician in things that you just can't
reasonably expect them to remember how
to address adjust drug dosage based on a
particular pharmacogenetic test as a
kind of my mind obvious example as risk
assessment comes of age i think that
will similarly be an example of
something that will benefit greatly from
point-of-care decision support tools
thirdly none of this is going to happen
without collaborative partnerships
as an example the generalist physician
should be in a position to recognize the
new technologies that their patients
could benefit from
and
just like in the case of inborn errors
of metabolism we'll very likely want to
identify a consultant expert who can
help i hope a medical geneticist will be
on their list of people whom they might
call upon in those situations
but nonetheless
they have an important role to play
i certainly would not
posit that specialists say cardiologists
or neurologists or oncologists are
inevitably always going to refer to a
medical geneticist every time they want
genome sequence it's pretty clear that
won't be the case
it strongly favored the notion of
creating
focused fellowships that a cardiologist
could do say a one-year fellowship in
cardiovascular genetics that does not
require them to master all of the
details that a medical geneticist will
master if you're an adult cardiologist
you probably don't need to know a whole
lot about treating newborns with
congenital anomalies
so creating partnership
focused fellowships is something that i
strongly favor and where there have been
active discussions to create those kind
of training paths
and i do think we are going to need new
counseling paradigms when you've got a
genome's worth of information to discuss
with an individual no you can't sit in
the room going gene by gene so i think
we do need to
have new ways of imparting information
probably some of which will be web-based
various apps that
may be able to customize the message to
the particular genetic findings of the
given individual
i think there's huge opportunities and
sort of the entrepreneurial world to be
building both new educational and new
counseling approaches
so i think
in summary i'll make the point that
although
there are many cautions i think i have
alluded to in this talk so far
i'll tell you that i tend to be
optimistic
about how all of this will play out
i
strongly believe that genomics will be a
major engine of progress
in medicine in the coming generation not
the only one but one of the major ones
and for all of the challenges i guess my
fundamental belief is that the medical
community has risen to challenges like
this before
we
cite imaging as an example when i train
mri was just beginning to be introduced
and
now it's it's used on a routine basis
and i think in general well-used i'd be
hard-pressed to tell you any great
detail about the basic physics of mri
but
hasn't stopped me and my colleagues from
using it on a routine basis and i think
um to
better help health of our patients i
think the same will happen in genomics
the
main
way to look at this from my perspective
is this means new
opportunities for those who are inclined
towards sort of creating cutting-edge
paradigms in my mind that's what makes
this time really such an exciting one
which to be practicing
i need to direct you um to this
website which or this link apparently
the actual link is not functioning
but i'll take questions in just a moment
and leave this slide up but those of you
who are
interested in continuing education
credits should know
that you go to this link and
arrange to get your cnes so i will
conclude at this point i very much
appreciate the opportunity to
participate i hope this
was helpful
and
we'll
then
take questions and
notice that
there
are some so i guess one question was
how do we get the pdf that
i publish i think what you're referring
to probably
the pdf of this presentation
will be available on this site but that
may not be what you're referring to i
wonder
if you were referring instead to the
ibook that i
alluded to a few slides back
so that is not in the ibook store it
actually was for a few minutes but we
realized it was probably not didn't
belong there because
these were slides present unprepared for
a particular course that was really very
narrowly targeted
and we're in the process of kind of
upgrading it so that it's
available on a more general basis
anybody specifically interested um can
send me an email which is bcorf uab.edu
and we can talk about how to make that
available if that's
what you're interested in
i don't see any other questions on the
display i guess i can pause for a minute
and see if any
come through the system
okay so the question is there is seeming
disconnect between physicians
and advanced knowledge especially in
basic sciences how can this be bridged
so my answer to that i guess it comes
back to that
hhmi double amc
document and i thought the point of that
first of all
was to rethink the way basic science is
taught and to focus on the things that
really matter in terms of
clinical action because
at least in my mind the goal
is that
you want physicians to be
inquisitive
and to be
interested in and alert to
what the basic science underpinnings of
their practice are
but
you don't necessarily
expect that they are going to be sort of
experts at the basic science
of
every fine detail of everything that
they do and going back to the example of
imaging
i told you before i don't really
understand the physics of mri and i'd be
very surprised if many of my colleagues
did
but the truth is i
actually think that
the
kind of general ability to have an idea
of what's being
done with an mri and what the different
sequences are
good for identifying
has benefited from having some basic
science knowledge of nmr and realizing
that this is not a black box that
magically produces pictures and that
there are ways of getting artifacts so
having some basic science knowledge
there helps even though
you don't consciously use it every time
so i think we need to rethink
the
way medical school
curricula are organized the way the
pre-health professional curricula are
organized
and i think we need to embed this in the
point of care and into the cme
opportunities but not you know i think
the biggest mistake we make is by going
into such fine detail about the nuts and
bolts of the basic science that it loses
people and they don't really see the
value it's not an easy area but i do
think that it can be done a lot better
um so there's a question i guess it
refers back
about
the book
that
we published for clinicians
and
i'm not actually sure what book that was
referred to the only book i spoke about
specifically
picturing
the slides
is
i don't know if i can go back to it it
was
i believe
this one here that that's the book
that's being referred to that's the
ibook i was talking about before um that
i'd be happy to share
um as we sort of upgraded and i mean
there are many books out there and we'll
go into details about um individual
books but
there are many that are available that
can be used to get up to speed on this
and there's a
point i believe it is equally important
to educate patients on genomic
interpretations so they can have a
productive
conversation with their physicians and
the successful overall outcome of
clinical care so i absolutely agree with
that
and you know i
go back to the slide that was the point
of this slide the idea was that you know
the general undergraduate and i realized
obviously this is relevant to people who
knows they go to college
but i would make a strong argument for
incorporating some of the very elemental
principles into
secondary school education and into
certainly into post-secondary education
i think the scientific community needs
to be prepared to articulate the
opportunities and the challenges in a
clear way to the consumer public the
general public there are various efforts
to do this on a formal basis
web-based efforts for example i know
that some groups have
put together that
are available i think it's another area
of huge need and opportunity and has to
be done carefully and well and what i
mean by that
is the same temptation to delve into the
kind of needs of all the details is a
real mistake
because it creates the impression that
this is you know too complicated to
possibly understand
and i guess one of the central messages
of my talk is
this is more complicated than it seems
and therefore needs to be done carefully
and thoughtfully by people who know what
they're doing
however
as you know any complex area um there
ought to be a way to communicate the
sort of the core of it so that people
understand it and are not afraid of it
and part of of course having them not be
afraid of it is to instill confidence
that the people that they're able to
talk to about it actually know what
they're doing but i think a
partnership between informed
patients and consumers and informed
professionals is really the goal that we
should be seeking
all right i don't see any other
questions i'll pause again in a minute
in case
any come along
we would be able to review the lecture
it's my understanding that these are
archived
and available for view after
this session is over
so i'm pretty certain that the answer is
yes though i guess you'd have to contact
one of the
people involved in setting this up to
know exactly how it's done but yes is
the answer
okay any other questions
all right well i think we are pretty
close to the end of the time i guess i
will conclude at this point really
appreciate your attention and interest
and um
hope that this was helpful to all of you
so thanks very much